bonjour et bienvenue dans bienvvre la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans
Nivine mène avec les SEP communes qui
composent le territoire une politique de
santé ambitieuse si si vous allez le
voir en s'appuyant notamment sur
l'Institut de promotion de la santé ce
mois-ci donc dans bien vivre gros
checkup on prend le pou de la santé à
Saint-Quentin
en première agglomération la Bellis
ville santé par l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé
50 Anel développe une politique de santé
locale publique autour de 5 axes
prioritaires premier c'est le parcours
de santé pour la prévention l'accès aux
soins le second c'est la santé des
jeunes avec disons toujours prévention
prévention des conduites à risque des
addictions la santé mentale pour
accompagner toutes les personnes qui
peuvent souffrir de troubles mentaux le
cadre de vie qui est aussi quelque chose
de très très important bien-être
environnement c'est important pour la
santé et puis le dernier c'est la Géront
et le handicap que nous n'avions pas
jusqu'à maintenant mais qui nous paraît
très important vu le vieillissement de
la population aujourd'hui même si c'est
une population qui est quand même
relativement en bonne santé pour le plus
grand nombre et pour mener à bien ces
projets la cas qui s'appuie notamment
sur l'Institut de promotion de la santé
également appelé IPS c'est un service de
la communauté d'agglomération de ans
en ça a été créé dans le but de servir
la population de 5 ans en Yveline autour
des questions de santé de permettre aux
habitants de mieux accéder au droit à la
santé on est un bâtiment qui héberge une
vingtaine de structures d'association
des médecins bénévo d'un lieu écou de
jeune qui c'est une psychologue qui
reçoit des jeunes de manière anonyme et
gratuite un centre de soins
d'accompagnement en de prévention en
addictologie réseau de soins palliatifs
toutes ces associations ces institutions
sont regroupées ici dans un but de
proximité et
d'accessibilité on a également un
accueil de promotion en santé donc cet
accueil de promotion en santé c'est un
accueil qui est ouvert toute la semaine
donc de 9h à 12h30 de 14h à 18h et qui
permet une écoute une orientation de la
population sur les questions de santé
voilà l'IPS c'est tout ça à la fois on
reçoit 8000 habitants par an personne
comme Joë Bertoin venu faire un bilan de
santé aïe aïe aïe ça pique ça non ça va
c'est la première fois que vous venez
c'est la deuxième fois je suis déjà venu
en mars
2008 un bilan de santé tous les 5 ans
pourquoi pas hein j'ai un certain âge
aujourd'hui donc j'ai 66 ans j'ai
regardé tout à l'heure tout ce qu'on
avait fait en 2008 des examens là
c'est complet prévenir c'est dir
n'est-ce pas et pour ce bilan Joël
retraité a été reçu par l'IPC une des
nombrebreuses associations hébergées à
l'IPS l'IPC ça veut dire investigation
préventive et clinique c'est une
association qui est conventionnée par la
Sécurité
Sociale loi 1901 pour réaliser donc
l'examen périodique de
santé on reçoit uniquement des personnes
en situation de précarité sur l'antenne
de trappe c'est les personnes qui sont
au chômage au RSA personnes
handicapées les personnes qui sont
retraités les étudiants alors au sein de
de l'IPC ça consiste à recevoir tout le
tous les publics qu'on voit afin que je
puisse réaliser des entretiens sociaux
pour que je puisse accompagner les
personnes ou les réorienter vers des
structures et l'avantage d'être au sein
de l'IPS c'est d'avoir énormément de
structure déjà pour à proximité de
pouvoir parler aux personnes des
associations qui
existent
si on peut comment dirais-je par le
biais de ces examens éviter bien des
choses parce que en amont on a fait le
nécessaire c'est que c'est bien
quelqu'un disait si vous permettez la
plus belle phrase pour être heureux faut
avoir un corps qui vous fout la paix
très bien on vous laisse donc partir en
pai on se tourne vers un autre pilier
d'importance de cette politique de santé
volontaire le groupement gandicap
considéré comme un pôle médico-social
novateur et pourquoi donc Isabelle
arochan gandicap c'est un groupement qui
regroupe des services conçus pour
favoriser le maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées des personnes en
situation de
handicap tous les services toutes les
structures de G handicap s'adressent aux
personnes directement concernées
personnes âgées ou personnes en
situation deic cap à leur entourage ou
aux professionnels qui les accompagnent
au quotidien les structures qui
accompagnent directement euh les
personnes on en a vu certains exemples
il y a l'équipe spécialis Alzheimer il y
a la coordination gérontologique il y a
des accueils de jour trois actions phar
les les entrées d' café les ateliers
pratiques et les groupes de parole et
puis pour les les les professionnels
c'est un centre de de ressources et un
centre de formation euh pour toutes les
techniques d'accompagnement au domicile
pour t les compétences de
l'accompagnement au domicile il y a des
des services qui viennent aussi en
soutien à leur famille un programme
d'action de soutien aux aidents
notamment les formations proposées à gér
handicap sont proposées pour tous les
professionnels de
l'accompagnement des auxiliaires de vie
qui interviennent auprès des personnes
des aides soignants des soignants des
des des infirmiers mais également
jusqu'au médecin sur place l'équipe
spécialisée Alzheimer apporte aux
familles une aide précieuse l'équipe
spécialisée Alzheimer est une est une
équipe qui intervient donc à domicile
chez les personnes directement qui sont
atteintes de la maladie d'Alzheimer de
maladie apparenté et de la maladie de
Parkinson nous intervenons donc sur 12 à
15 séances par an qui sont prises en
charge à 100 % par la Sécurité sociale
nous mettons en place donc des activités
selon les capacités et les difficultés
des personnes ici c'est un appartement
donc pédagogique qui donc sert
principalement à montrer un petit peu
comment on s'oriente et comment on
fonctionne avec le domicile des
personnes des exemples
d'activités donc là par exemple il y a
une donc une recette simplifiée parce
que donc souvent les personnes qui ont
la maladie d'Alzheimer ont des
difficultés dans la succession des
tâches mettre les recettes un petit peu
par par fonction et puis dire ce qu'il
faut faire ça les aide par exemple c'est
une carte une carte de France avec les
villes à replacer donc c'est bien parce
que ça fait également appel à la mémoire
des personnes et à côté un jeu qui est
un petit peu plus basé sur les maths
voilà on a créé un jeu de société par
rapport à la gestion de l'argent avec
une liste de courses voilà et puis les
personnes doivent établir un budget
voilà et gérer un budget il y a
également tout ce qui est gym douce au
domicile des personnes nous intervenons
une fois par semaine et à hauteur
d'unhure à 2h par semaine
les liens avec j'ai handicap au
démarrage c'est par le fait de du
problème des problèmes de santé de mon
mari l'équipe spécialisée Alzheimer donc
qui est intervenu pendant 3 mois pour
mon mari puisque c'est 3 mois une heure
une fois par semaine et c'est
pluridisciplinaire donc c'est très
intéressant pour la personne malade pour
voir un petit peu son environnement
aussi s'il y a des choses à rectifier
l'équipa s'est même occupé pour ne pas
interrompre de me trouver une
orthophoniste à domicile pour poursuivre
l'action parce que l'action s'est révélé
très très bénéfique mon mari est prise
en charge par un assistant de vie qui
lui fait faire un petit peu de promenade
de temps en temps parce que moi je vois
pas trop promener avec lui parce que si'
tombe je risque de pas pouvoir le
rattraper et tomber
avec en ce qui me concerne en tant
qu'aidante euh je participe aux
activités qui sont dispensées par le
groupe d'aide aux aidents de gérondcap
vous entrez dans café on se retrouve
dans un café à sur la ville nouvelle de
sa-quanttin en Éveline où il y a un
exposé d'un intervenant spécialisés il y
a aussi les ateliers qui sont réservés
aux aidents et qui sont aussi très
intéressants quand on peut être
disponible pour moi je je trouve que
c'est une un bon un bon élément pour
avoir une relation avec d'autres
personnes qui sont dans la même
situation le prochain thème est
particulièrement intéressant parce que
c'est ce qu'on arrive pas souvent à
faire c'est comment s'occuper de de
soi-même en s'occupant des
autres et ça c'est pas toujours
évident termineront enfin avec une bonne
nouvelle de futures maisons
pluridisciplinaires de santé sont
actuellement en construction à montigier
le Bretonneux et à Guy encour elles
faciliteront l'accès aux soins de tous
les 50tinois et réuniront dans un même
lieu des médecins généralistes des
infirmiers ou encore des dentistes et
voici donc pour la santé à Saint-Quentin
en yeline et maintenant on retrouve nos
Actu du
mois et nos Actu du mois sont en fait ce
mois-ci de bons plans attention c'est
parti mon premier concerne les
Championnats du monde de cyclisme qui se
tiendront du 18 au 22 février 2015 au
Vélodrome national et bien sachez que
les 50inois qui souhaitent y assister
bénéficieront de tarifs réduits et oui
il suffit d'habiter l'une des SEP
communes du territoire et de se
présenter au Vélodrome muni d'un
justificatif de domicile à partir de
mi-novembre la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en Eveline se
sépare de ses anciens équipements et
organise sa 10e vente via le site à
gorastore jusqu'au 11 novembre ce ris
sur le gâteau un Renault traffic de
Peugeot Boxer de Kango diesel et trois
clios GPL sont également proposés aux
enchè et voici pour nos Actu du mois
quant un are dossier vous pouvez le
retrouver dans le petit Quentin du mois
de novembre un petit Quentin dans lequel
vous pouvez retrouver également un
article sur la fête du compte un autre
sur la filière aéronautique à
saint-centin en Yveline et pour terminer
le portrait de cquantinois qui ont passé
de semaines sans voiture à l'occasion de
la Semaine de la mobilité voilà c'était
dans bien vivre et nous on se retrouve
le mois prochain à
bientôt